described to us the moment
not only finding it but you know
seeing what it looked like
i mean it's great to be here with you
it's particularly great because you're
crediting me with the whole thing i'd
love to pretend that i did find it i was
just watching them work hard i was
watching archaeologist manson bound and
his sub feed team working around the
clock for a month in some of the most
hideous conditions on planet earth it
was minus 35 degrees of windshield they
were working through the night all day
they were fixing these unmanned vehicles
they were then sending to 3 000 meters
to the seabed through a thick sheet of
sea ice it was brutal working conditions
all i had to do was post the odd picture
on instagram so i had the easiest job on
the ship let me tell you but when we
discovered it when the expedition
discovered it it was like a miracle we
could not believe the state's the ship
the wood there are no wood-eating
microorganisms no little animals that
feed on wood like there are elsewhere in
the wild oceans it's too cold and
there's no wooden touch because they
haven't evolved to live down there and
on the seabed so the ship is
almost perfectly preserved you mentioned
it sank on the 21st november 1915 i
think it looks much it did that day when
shackleton saw it sink he wrote his
diary i don't think i can write about it
he was so depressed and i think he'd
been so happy that now that wasn't the
end of insurance that was just the end
of a chapter and now a whole new chapter
can begin
yeah i mean incredible a historian's
dream isn't this it's a
once-in-a-lifetime uh discovery surely
uh talk us through and tell the viewers
about the it wasn't just the sinking of
the ship but actually shackleton and his
crew's extraordinary escape as well can
you tell us a bit about that
you're absolutely right although you did
say this once in a lifetime i'm
beginning to think is this it this is
this is going to get for me now there's
nothing else made me feel a bit
depressed there for a moment
but you're right you will have more
doubt
i i doubt it to be honest it's never
going to get better but you're right
what's really amazing about this this
shipwreck is it connects to us all to
the story of shackleton it is
unbelievable and for those people who
need a sort of a bit of a peg a bit of
help getting into history i think this
is going to be that
and it's going to connect us to this
story which is one of the great
most epic survival escape stories of all
time
it was crushed in the ice it said they
lived on the ice floating around the sea
ice for another few months then they
took to small rowing boats they managed
to get across this sea here that i'm now
traversing and they made it elephant
island a scrap of land very very
isolated then shackleton took an elite
crew
of six men from elephant island 800
miles to south georgia across the
southern ocean gigantic storms hurricane
force winds absolutely extraordinary
streak he then walked across south
georgia the first person to ever do so
hiked across the glaciers this discovery
um i i've got a quote from marine
archaeologist manson bound who's also
part of the discovery expedition he says
without any exaggeration this is the
finest wooden shipwreck i have ever seen
by far i want to ask you dan then what
next will it stay there in order to
preserve it or
is there even a possibility of raising
it up
well i've just been with benson bound
he's the chief archaeologist working
which it was his search area the reason
we found it he identified the search
area in the wedding scene and we've both
been mainlining coffee to stay awake and
lots of interviews is very exciting he's
been doing this for 30 years he says
he's never seen anything like it
we didn't touch it
we didn't interfere with it it's a
survey mission we came back with a
beautiful millimeter perfect 3d laser
scan with incredible super high
definition camera footage um and
that's all we've done we've mapped it
we've it can now be protected and
respected and studied in the future
who knows in decades time they may have
the technology to reach down raise it up
and preserve it somewhere for all of
humankind but that's a long way off but
certainly no plans do anything with it
in the in the near term
right and and what does this mean for
other shipwrecks around the world
well i think what it means is it
hopefully will add rocket fuel to
people's fascination with what lies
about our oceans there are there's
probably more heritage more treasures on
our ocean floor than there are all the
museums of the world combined so we do
have the technology now to see down to
those wrecks we and we have a duty to
protect them because there are people
out there bad actors who want to sell
who want to you know loot and and
desecrate those wrecks so i think for
people like me we'd love to get down
there get data on the wrecks broadcast
into the world help people i mean i
don't need much help
falling in love with history i've got to
say but for some people i can understand
they need a little bit of they need to
see something and to feel something and
i think when you broadcast these images
and these laser 3d models i think it
will just engage a whole generation in
not just for shackleton and antarctic
but with subsidy adventure in its
entirety
dan snow in antarctica thanks very much
indeed great to have your enthusiasm as
part of the program today thank you